bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8
nouvelle semaine en direct entre 18 et
19 heures pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale sur tv filet vous
allez découvrir dans un instant cette
statue ce trophée ce trophée ce bocuse
d'or et son lauréat qui se trouve juste
derrière bon sortie beau ruggeri bocuse
d'or 2013 vous avez remporté ce trophée
le 30 janvier dernier à lyon ces
olympiades de la gastronomie de la
cuisine on va en parler tout à l'heure
avec votre coach est également meilleur
ouvrier de france fabrice prochasson
bienvenue également sur ce plateau vous
nous direz comment vous avez vécu ces
derniers jours et puis comment s'est
passé le retour également du côté de
lenôtre à plaisir où vous travaillez
mais pour le moment voici les titres de
ce 11 février les sujets que nous allons
développer ce soir dans l'actualité la
problématique des aires d'accueil des
gens du voyage à travers l'exemple de la
zone d'accueil de trappes des gens du
voyage aimerait bien si sédentarisés
mais une nouvelles directives les
obligent à quitter les lieux au bout de
cinq mois de présence à l'école
nationale supérieure du paysage de
versailles forme aux métiers du paysage
des étudiants diplômés d'un bac + 2 une
journée portes ouvertes a eu lieu ce
samedi une autre sera organisé le 16
février
présentation de l'association arts
magiques à montigny le bretonneux une
association qui propose des cours de
danse et de musique parmi les
disciplines enseignées la zumba et la
salsa et puis en sport le club de tennis
de table de voisins-le-bretonneux
organisé pour la quatrième année
consécutive une compétition régionale à
l'occasion de voir évoluer la crème des
joueurs franciliens et pour le point
complet sur l'actualité sportive comme
chaque lundi 18h30 anthony rech qui
revient tout bronzé du ski
frissonner bonsoir a tous un 7,8 sport
très riche ce soir nous parlerons boxe
éducative après les championnats
régionaux minimes où le boxing de la
verrière s'est illustré mais aussi
cyclisme avec isabelle gautheron vous ne
la connaissez peut-être pas mais c'est
l'ancienne championne de france sur
piste qui est la marraine du vélo-club
d'elancourt saint quentin en yvelines et
de gymnastique artistique après les
championnats régionaux organisés à
guyancourt et puis comme d'habitude en
fin d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end ne bougeait pas à tout à
l'heure à retenir grande forme le ski
vos amis à y perdre leur but de globules
rouges pour cette chronique sport
l'essentiel des résultats du week-end à
retrouver d'ici une demi-heure pour le
moment comment devient ton champion du
monde de cuisine les secrets du bocuse
d'or 2013 s'est tout de suite
tibou ruggeri et fabrice prochasson donc
sont les invités de cette édition du 7 8
si vous nous rejoignez en direct
champion du monde de cuisine à lyon le
30 janvier dernier vous le savez
d'ailleurs si vous nous avez suivi sur
cette antenne nous vous avions donné
elle les résultats en direct le palmarès
de ces véritables olympiades vous allez
découvrir le chiffre d'ailleurs de cette
édition le chiffre c'est 24 24 pays qui
se sont affrontés pendant deux jours il
y en avait même 60 au départ avant les
sélections nous sommes une dizaine de
jours après cet événement vous y pensez
encore la pression est redescendue mais
vous y pensez toujours bien sûr il ya
beaucoup de choses qui vous remettent le
concours en mémoire non c'est pas vieux
mais notamment beaucoup de
sollicitations des médias et même pas
mal d'agitation encore la compétition se
déroule pendant 5h35 il savait 5h35 pas
une minute de plus ça peut sembler
plutôt long mais au final pas tant que
ça parce que ya pas une seule assiette
envoyée c'était 14 pour lui c'est ça et
puis c'est vrai qu'on démarre la
compétition avec que des produits bruts
donc vous avez un filet de boeuf brut
vous avez un turbo brut des homards brut
vivent donc c'est relativement court
même ultra court c'est vraiment un
timing très serré et extrêmement minutes
et comment vous avez vécu l'événement et
puis comment vous avez vécu ces derniers
jours en vo
c'était toujours difficile d'approché
compétition dont on n'est pas sur place
automatiquement d'après moi je suis
arrivé un petit peu un observateur un
peu plus tôt les geeks and their le chef
la création de notre enfaite pour
donner un petit peu d'indications à
thibault on regarde les boks parce que
c'est les boks actuellement grosse
bagarre incertaine le champ de bataille
la reine on va dire des cuisines paul
bocuse et puis après ses derniers
préparatifs sont je suis parti en fer
dernier bris france ans le 25 après midi
puis après de liens permanents sont sms
entre les mails entre 12 ce qui se
passait ce n'a pas oublié les
difficultés à venir du concours c'est de
partir serein de plaisir donc thibault
c'était sa mission et fabrice bonnet qui
est meilleure et de france aussi chez
les nôtres qui était un deuxième coach
on adjoint direct si jamais il y avait
un problème toi tu es banques et des
matheux prévu et c'est clair que des
travailleuses et fortement vers le
vendredi soir le samedi le dimanche peut
pas faire tout les pesées vérifier qu'il
manquait rien donc tout matériel toutes
les assiettes c'est énormément de
travail et de préparation préparation au
mois de préparation bah c'est beaucoup
de travail parce que automatiquement
s'il est beaucoup d'anticipation et nous
on avoue travailler beaucoup sur le côté
conceptuel donc on n'a pas fait que de
la cuisine c'était un important dans le
concours ce que ça concours c'est un
show artistique c'est un show culinaire
et ibos un artiste logiquement donc
c'est important pour lui de jouer ce
côté justement du show mains de s'amuser
on va dire et vu qu'on avait utilisé le
thème de versailles justement on va voir
les images et un petit carnet
d'inspiration qui a été réalisé
justement alors là on voit les pleins
vous avez réalisés aussi bien pour la
viande que pour le poisson ensuite il ya
tout un petit croquis des petits dessins
explicatifs vous étiez base
effectivement sur le travail de lenôtre
de versailles alstom et châteaux comment
vous avez travaillé évoluer justement
voit les différents croquis c'est
vraiment de dollars on est dans l'art
dans la création artistique
véritablement le sujet qui arrivent et 5
juillet d'après ben c
se met au vert comme andy comme les
footballeur universal germain ou autre
et puis après réfléchir et les idées
sont venus assez spontanément comment
vous avez élaboré justement ces
différentes recettes on peut peut-être
les redonner voilà pour le poisson vous
avez travaillé quoi plus spécifiquement
poser turbo et omar donc nous on a fait
en fait un turbo en peau de homard doré
avec une garniture à la française qu'on
pouvait réfléchir en amont et en fait la
spécificité de cette dernière édition
c'est la présence d'un marché de
produits de saison avec lequel vous
devez composer de garnitures donc on
connaissait pas les produits de saison
donc on a composé vraiment nos deux
garnitures la veille du concours et
ensuite pour notre garniture à la
française c'était une garniture une
tartelette truffe donc là on est
vraiment à l'apogée de la saison de la
truffe donc on était en plein dedans
voilà grosso modo plan français et puis
rappelez vous on avait fait un déjà un
petit marché en exercice parce que vous
n'avez anticipé déjà un petit peu sur la
région effectivement nous étions venus
vous voir on avait réchauffé ce
reportage lors de votre victoire lors de
la préparation du côté de plaisir
puisque l'entreprise le nôtre français
basé sur plaisir donc cette première
place ce trophée ce podium vous aviez
terminé 5e pourtant lors de l'épreuve
européenne ça vous avait mis une petite
pression supplémentaire
ou peut-être en tout cas leur enlever de
la pression peut-être effectivement
l'objectif pour la sélection européenne
s'était terminé dans les cinq premiers
sachant qu'on a eu un laps de
préparation qui était le plus faible
enfin le plus court de tous on a eu
contre la sélection française et europe
on a eu neuf jours et encore pour se
préparer donc on y aller un peu pour
pour se qualifier avant tout c'est vrai
que pour nous le vrai enjeu c'était la
finale monde où là on repartait tous
avec la même donne le même règlement et
tout le monde était
comprenez qu'on ait connaissance plutôt
du règlement en même temps cette photo
du podium de cette première place
obtenue à vos côtés les représentants du
danemark et du japon le japon qui est
d'ailleurs présent à chaque finale
depuis le début de la compétition c'est
en 1987 ce sont des nations qui qui
s'impose de plus en plus véritablement
sur la scène mondiale de la cuisine
parce que en france en est chauvin quand
on dit cuisine on pense pas danemark au
japon ou alors pour les sushis peut-être
mais il n'ya pas que ça ce sont des pays
qui progresse et des pays qui ont conçu
s'adapter aux règlements des concours
mettre en place des équipes techniques
gérer pratiquement les directions
techniques de cuisine qui prennent les
meilleurs français aussi voir d'autres
mais de france info qu'il renouvelle
donc un ami personnel vous inquiéter
l'entraîneur aussi de dire du japon donc
automatiquement les smarties est
utilisée grâce à nos champions français
aussi et puis après je pense que cdp qui
aime bien se bagarrer nation prend le
danemark qu'on sait c'est des vikings
avant tout de son mari de l'europe et le
monde entier on va dire qu'il a gagné la
compétition il ya deux ans il ya deux
ans le boxeur de façon le danemark était
dans les favoris bon coût de gens les
critiques est désormais installé ils
vont faire le huitième ou neuvième mois
j'étais persuadé qu'il serait là parce
qu'on les connaît bien loué thibault on
vraiment bien communiquer avec eux avec
leur coach avec l'ancien candidat
vainqueur eh ben on savait qu'ils
seraient présents après un concours
reste un concours et ce jour là c'est
sûr difficile il ya le climat dans le
mode qui est très important et beaucoup
de courants d'air et que c'est froid il
y avait du show du low cost vous êtes
dans des boxes ouais c'est un détail
mais c'était difficile j'avais une
hauteur importante cette année et tout
ça bout il faut anticiper il faut
préparer il faut avoir les bonnes infos
pour justement veiller que tu parviens
je pense que là dessus nous a trahis et
beaucoup là dessus on n'a pas travaillé
comme j'ai créé cuisine à vraiment
entrer sur l'ensemble des dossiers et
tout ça permet a permis à ty bos
travaille dans de très bonnes conditions
après c'est à lui d'y effectuer leur 7e
journée c'est extra light ont bien
réussi leur il a plutôt apprécié les
actes c'était super et nous on est très
content et puisqu'on parle de ces
différentes cuisines du monde on fait
juste une petite parenthèse nous sommes
allés à votre rencontre aujourd'hui
notre question du jour quelle cuisine du
monde vous intéresse vous passionne quel
type de cuisine recherchée vous
asiatiques
parce que plein de d'arômes des pis
pour travailler pas mal les aliments
ce très fins la cuisine très fine on
digère bien donc c'est plutôt pas mal
bah toutes les cuisines du monde je suis
très curieux - très gourmand très
gourmand est donc très curieux je voyage
beaucoup donc j'apprécie toutes les
cuisines du monde j'aime bien la cuisine
asiatique oui tout simplement sa chance
de la routine un haut lieu de pas de bus
tec j'ai grand classique la purée etc
c'est quand même plus sympa des petits
nems de temps en temps et et sauce
orientale la cuisine japonaise pour son
côté tiré diététique quoi qui fait pas
grossir et voilà française
je suis habitué et puis après de la
chinoise à la cuisine asiatique parce
que ça a des saveurs complètement
différente par rapport à la nôtre et
puis ça on ça se fait rapidement ça se
mange bien sans problème
la cuisine asiatique qui passionne les
saint quentinois les yvelinois ça vous
surprend pas pas plus que ça une pop
plus que ça ce que moi j'ai beaucoup
depuis une quinzaine d'années on va dire
depuis tout petit on va dire au monde
entier et depuis on va dire 30 ans dans
le côté professionnel et la première
cuisine mondiale toute façon qu'on fait
livrer leurs recherches aujourd'hui
c'était comme la chine qu'il avait créé
on ne s'était pas vraiment une cuisine
s'est associé la médecine et en
consommer pour se guérir ou pour grandir
je dirais pour évoluer dans la vie non
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui cette culture
monde du bien-être d'une cuisine saine à
s'équilibrer en général pas trop grasse
avec beaucoup d'éléments beaucoup de
vitamines beaucoup d'oligo-éléments et
beaucoup d'herbe dépis permet une
cuisine qui tout le monde pas accepter
même sur la connais pas après
culturellement c'est difficile parce que
en chine il ya plein de régions donc on
connaît principalement neuf grandes
régions chinoises 28 mai n'a plus de 18
ans fait et après son retour du vietnam
sont des soldats ou ce qu'on valait donc
chacun peut décliner à sa façon ses
cuisines sa mode formation suivant aussi
ce qu'ils ont une stabilité mais ces
gens-là bon ont une culture du partage
on en plein de nouvel an chinois en ce
moment j'ai participé ce week-end et
c'est clair que je pense que la victoire
du japon bocuse d'or n'est pas une
surprise victoire je parle d'avoir une
médaille de baptême au pouce important
que l'adisq a représenté avec une
médaille de bronze c'est exceptionnel
je pense que de voir un chinois monté
sur un peu de mots tus d'or ce sera
possible de l'envisageable 12 ans 14 ans
donc vous est intarissable sur
l'histoire de la cuisine à travers le
monde faire une émission spéciale juste
et de l'injuste sur sa finale sur c'est
sur ce sur ce palmarès est sûre ce
premier prix que vous avez décroché
j'aurais tout de même savoir votre
sentiment quand vous avez reçu ce bocuse
d'or des mains de paul bocuse puisqu'il
était présent il vous l'a remis tout
même on revoir l'ajustement de la photo
de paul bocuse rappeler son cv en ses
trois étoiles au guide michelin depuis
1965 cuisinier du siècle pape de la
cuisine chef du siècle aussi se sont
tous les titres et les surnoms qui lui
sont attribués vous avez ressenti quoi
un grand moment de fierté peut-être vous
voyez un grand moment de fierté c'est
évident c'est vrai que jusqu'à
l'aboutissement du palmarès rien n'était
joué parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
grosses équipes sachant que nous quand
on est le moment entre notre entrée dans
le box jusqu'au palmarès on n'avait vu
aucun plat passé n'y a qu'une assiette
donc on n'avait aucune idée de ce qu'ils
avaient fait les autres donc ça a été un
grand ouf de soulagement c'est vrai que
immense joie et puis ça devenait
vraiment couronner un travail d'équipé
joue avec les équipes de chez lenôtre on
a fait un boulot
conséquent sur le plat et sur l'assiette
de poissons et c'est vrai que c'est
d'autant plus plaisant que c'est un
bonheur qui est partagée qui répartis
sur toute l'équipe plutôt de quelque
chose que vous gardez vous tout seul et
vous avez pu le sentir dans la tribune a
lyon il y avait une osmose avec le
public enfin
c'était c'était géant et c'est vraiment
partagé
combien de personnes qui ont pleuré
enfin c'est une vraie compétition par
ddt olympiades mais véritablement ce
sont des olympiades il ya un public des
supporters qui se présente devant dehors
de la scène sert transmis à travers le
monde entier vous le dit c'est une
équipe il ya une personne qui n'est pas
présent que ce soir c'est votre commis
exactement c'est d'ailleurs de l'épreuve
julie l'humour voilà donc julie qui est
inquiets pop hip hop bas depuis être là
ce soir
pourtant tu as fait un travail
phénoménal c'est vrai que on a toujours
temps sur comment dire le l'intérieur du
box comme un binôme plutôt qu'une
relation un chef et commis donc tu as
fait julie qui a fait un travail
extraordinaire et qui a vraiment
d'immenses qualités vous avez été
accompagnée d'un commis pour réaliser
ces plats aussi pour faire votre marché
c'était les spécificités parce que
l'épreuve évoluent tous les deux ans
peut peut-être s'y attarder aussi ça
renforce un petit peu la difficulté de
cette épreuve il a fallu aller faire
votre marché le matin ou la veille avant
laissé seul avec du concours en fait
donc il y avait un marché de produits de
saison des cinq continents c'était
l'intitulé du règlement on en savait
strictement pas plus donc donc ce qu on
a pu constater ce qu'on pense en tout
cas c'est que c'est vraiment une
excellente chose parce que ça ça vient
casser cette mécanique de répétition
tout le temps et ça fait vraiment place
de la spontanéité de la vraie cuisine
comme une creative cuisine créative de
saison passionnant et puis il ya un jury
aussi juste pour l'hygiène aussi sur le
respect le non-gaspillage également
c'était important pour le changement du
concours régis marcon et le comité
d'organisation du bocuse d'or a vraiment
voulu d'apporter on va dire à une
session nouvelle moderne entre
guillemets parce que c'est important que
le cuisinier fasse attention aussi une
paix durable tout ce qui y viennent tous
qui on va dire santé et autres et
d'avoir mis 200 points meilleur sur le
trail de la cuisine dont la moitié était
vraiment sur les battous qui est échue
tu les pertes et pour éviter que les
cuisiniers commande je pas même un kilo
de boeuf pour en faire que 2 kilos ou de
la perte de légumes pour lors du marché
a permis de concentrer un petit peu
j'aurais les chefs
créatif pratiquement
qui gère un petit peu tous ces éléments
là qui font attention dans le travail
aussi et permettre une migration de
cuisine si plus évoluer automatiquement
si on réfléchi à tout ça en général une
cuisine qui est très intéressante et ç'a
permis je pense de faire la différence
et politiquement au japon on fait
attention à tout ça le déchirent les
mais pas n'importe comment on utilise
vraiment partie money tous les produits
danemark c'est pareil là sur une petite
île que je pense que ce n'est pas par
hasard le podium et il est vraiment pas
par hasard moi j'avais vraiment ciblé
c'est à peu de surprises un peu de
podium c'est bien la première place mais
c'est notre vie dans ce sens n'a même
pas s'entraîner les six années
l'entrainement et thibaut les a
fortement endetté avec judy sur le tri
sélectif donc on a commandé une poubelle
spécifiques avec des couleurs de
couvercles différentes que ben c'est pas
facile parce que quand on fait jeter le
sopalin qui mouillent de l'eau on le met
où le sopalin où il y avait de la
matière grasse et où plein de réflexes
voilà exactement et c'est vrai que c'est
vrai qu'en cuisine qu'on ne fait pas
tous les jours mais qui est
indispensable de toute façon j'aurais
même aujourd'hui dont les ministères et
j'en parle de toute façon des maires de
france je pense qu'il faut intégrer sa
maman laisse happer dans les bacs
technique et plus examen on devra avoir
maintenant 10 15% de notes sont autour
de tout ça parce que c'est important et
je pense que l'idée de régis marcon de
faire évoluer sur un marché qui est très
intéressant sur ce thème en ces règles
d'hygiène et le travail est important
pour le concours et redonne un petit peu
j'irai de l'esprit de compétition
ouverte à tous les pays est moins les
gros building équipes et des budgets
exceptionnel où toute arrivée prévue
sans surprise là le marché le chef
celui-ci n'est pas bon c'est pas lui qui
fait sa recette qu'on se voit tout de
suite stablement des chefs pour tout
leur talent et ils sont multiples qui
sont à récompenser c'est un
investissement lourd pour vous ou pour
pour l'entreprise le nôtre vous a
soutenu ses 18 mois je dis d'ailleurs
deux mois de travail maintenant c'est
quoi c'est un petit peu de repos et puis
il faut retourner à plaisir le notre
travail est un petit peu l'entreprise
voulait sans pression fait tout de même
oui oui bien sûr c'est pas c'est pas une
torture non effectivement un petit peu
de repos ça sera bienvenue à partir de
fin février puis en attendant bon
on savoure ces moments de partage les
retours des toutes ces personnes qui ont
suivi la compétition en direct c'est
vraiment c'est un régal chacun a
vraiment vécu le moment donc c'est en
profiter encore un petit peu est
possible de défendre son titre pas dans
deux ans pour les biens-fonds supportant
le prochain kolda français
en tout cas concourir non qu'on a gagné
peut pas vous avez gagné vous pouvez pas
ses regrets sa
sas et hiboux faut poser des questions
c'est vrai que c'est un concours qui est
très épanouissant parce que c'est un
petit peu comme un chef-d'oeuvre donc
vous fabriquez votre plat votre
vaisselle enfin vous faites vraiment
exactement ce que vous souhaitez faire
donc je peux comprendre que ça puisse
être très épanouissant après c'est vrai
que c'est aussi une préparation qui est
très lourde qui nécessite et qui
mobilise beaucoup de personnes je donc
on va déjà le digérer un petit peu et
puis on verra une chose après l'autre
merci beaucoup bravo à tous les deux
félicitations qui vaut jerry fabrice
prochasson et une pensée pour toute
votre équipe également gilles humeau qui
pouvait pas être avec nous ce soir tout
de même le palmarès de ces bocuse d'or
dix podiums pour la france vous me
corrigez ainsi je me trompe dix podiums
pour la france sept podiums en or la
france qui reste là la nation la plus
titrée et la norvège juste derrière et
huit podiums dont 4 en or on verra dans
les prochaines années comment cela
évolue merci donc à tous les deux et
félicitations l'actualité dans les
yvelines à présent c'est aussi la
problématique des heures d'accueil des
gens du voyage à travers l'exemple de la
zone d'accueil de trappes des gens du
voyage aimerait bien si sédentarisés
mais ces nouvelles directives les
obligent à quitter les lieux au bout de
cinq mois de présence voici les
explications
sophie et rebecca sont des gens du
voyage ces caravanes sont leurs maisons
mais pour elle pas question de prendre
la route elles ont toute leur vie ici
dans les yvelines comme elle a 28 autres
sédentaires vivent sur l'air d'accueil
desbruyères attrape une aire inadaptée
puisqu'elle est prévu pour des gens de
passage séjour maximum cinq mois jusqu'à
l'année dernière des dérogations leur
était accordé mais un nouveau règlement
a changé la donne seul exception avoir
un enfant scolarisé son n'a pas d'enfant
qui va à l'école faut qu'on soit laisse
pousser
mais s pulsé pour aller où on serait pas
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines gère les trois
aires d'accueil présente sur son
territoire dont celle ci elle assure
conseillers des places dans les environs
au bout des cinq mois mais ce que
demandent ces sédentaires c'est une
solution définitive obtenir une aire
familial c'est à dire une ère sans
limite de temps donc ça fait dix ans
qu'on fait les démarches pour être
reconnu
habitant de
daisy vinyle d'avoir un terrain
familiaux et
le temps d'aller dans tout le
département il est pratiquement rien qui
est prévu pour eux il ya une sorte de
terrain familial qui a été instituée à
plaisir il y en a un qui s'assimile à un
terrain familial à aux clayes-sous-bois
mais c'est tout ailleurs rien n'a été
prévu de cet ordre donc nous militons
justement pour que ça soit prévue dans
le cadre de programmes d'habitat la
casse qui reconnaît le problème et
renvoie la balle aux autres villes du
département
de défauts capacité d'accueil
et je pense que david
sait tout faire
réaliser
vide juridique pour les gens du voyage
sédentaires ou manque de volonté
politique
il semble que sophie et les autres
résidents doivent encore attendre pour
être reconnus comme de vrais trappistes
les opposants au mariage pour tous
poursuivent leurs efforts pour saisir le
conseil économique social et
environnemental cinq cent mille
signatures sont nécessaires et et
philippe brillault le maire divers
droite du chenet qui collecte depuis
plusieurs semaines les différentes
paraphe annonce avoir atteint
aujourd'hui les 512000 elle le
dépouillement est toujours en cours dans
une salle de sa commune nous reviendrons
dans notre édition de demain sur cette
action rappelons que les discussions à
l'assemblée sont terminés depuis ce
week-end plus de cinq mille amendements
étudiés le vote final est des députés
est prévu demain mardi 12 février demain
12 février justement en fête chrétienne
de mardi gras un rendez vous annuel qui
précède le début du carré mais pour
lequel il est coutume de se déguiser les
étudiants de l'université de versailles
saint quentin ont bien décidé de ne pas
passer à côté de l'événement